ministers of agriculture and fisheries
are expected to discuss a new proposal
by the Commission to bring together and
simplify to currently separate school
schemes the school fruit scheme and the
school milk scheme cutting through the
red tape and setting the funds to 230
million euros per school year the scheme
addresses a worrying trend European
children consume less and less fruit
vegetables and milk products with the
slogan eat well feel good it aims to
counter poor nutrition habits beginning
with children from school age it also
aims to raise awareness of the benefits
of a healthy diet and to fight against
obesity which affects one in three
European kids between six and nine years
old EU ministers will also continue
discussions on the new rules presented
by the Commission to further promote
European agricultural products the
objective is to open up new markets for
these products both on the internal and
export markets and to increase consumer
awareness of their quality finally
ministers will exchange views on the
future of the dairy sector in Europe
following the end of the quota system in
2015